do you forget the feeling like you're
being watched the other day I was
thinking about buying this blanket
online and I put it in my car but then
kind of waffle because it was expensive
and then I got distracted and did
something else I just received a
personal Facebook message from the
company reminding me that it's in my
cart how do they do that I don't even
use the same email addresses for these
accounts it's Facebook listening to me
don't go getting fit for your tinfoil
hat just yet there isn't any hard
evidence that Facebook is
surreptitiously accessing your phone's
mic and even if they could the volumes
of data they'd have to analyze to
eavesdrop on just their American users
would be about 20 petabytes per day 33
times more than their total daily data
consumption
besides online tracking technology is so
advanced these days they don't really
need to you're dropping bread crumbs
everywhere you go
[Music]
imagine if you went to a shopping mall
and had an employee follow you around
upselling the entire time don't you just
love that shirt give me your email and
I'll give you five dollars off right now
hey remember that yoga mat you looked at
last week well guess what five other
people just bought it and say it's the
best ever 10% off if you buy it right
now hey don't forget it's your mom's
birthday next week she love this
hilarious coffee mug or maybe this fancy
candle three for the price of one if you
just use this code no one likes being
badgered by an overly excited employee
but that's basically what's happening
when you shop online and it can take a
serious toll on our bank accounts so
let's get clear on what companies are
really doing and what we can do about it
the main tactic that tailors use is
called online behavioral advertising
it's pretty darn sophisticated and
getting more so every day here's how it
works first a website will implant a
small piece of data on your computer
known as cute but this cookie comes with
strings attached it tracks how you
maneuver around website what pages you
click on how long you hang out there
what you search for what you add to your
cards it then hardness this data and use
it to build a profile it tries to guess
things like your age your income bracket
your likes and dislikes all in hopes of
serving you ads that are most likely to
capture your attention as new parents we
do most of our shopping online which
makes us prime targets Julia was
recently served up an ad for baby
booties that don't slip off if you
didn't know keeping socks or shoes on
baby's feet is basically impossible so
of course my attention will capture I
click the link and wouldn't you know it
five minutes later I was checking out
and now those shoes pop up on every site
I'm on I feel like I can't escape
cookies this is a textbook example of
retargeting only 2% of users will become
a customer on their first visit
so a cookies job is to quietly follow
you around cyberspace waiting for the
right time to inviting you back to their
store if every tailor has gotten access
to your contact information like your
email you will also be bashed with
personalized ads and offers Amazon is
the absolute king of this tactic say you
buy a yoga mat they will assume you
probably need this awesome yoga shirt oh
and you got a have you the blocks and
what about yoga socks these approaches
are super effective a retargeted ad is
70% more likely to become a paying
customer than a randomly served one
Amazon is also famous for leveraging
something called social proof our
tendency to copy the actions of others
because we assume they know more than we
do this is why 87% of users report that
they use customer reviews to decide on a
purchase of course because this is the
Internet this has led to an entire
hidden economy of sellers paying people
to write fake reviews for their products
Amazon claims that the percentage of
reviews that are fraudulent is tiny but
they don't really have much of an
incentive to crack down on them because
the more good reviews the more sales
there are websites that will analyze a
product page and tell you how many of
the reviews are suspect but the methods
these sites views are not proven to be a
hundred percent accurate all this
wouldn't be so bad if going online was
something you did every once in a while
and according to recent Nielsen study
Americans spend approximately 11 hours
per day staring at screens
that's like spending half your life in a
shopping mall it's no surprise that one
out of every three dollars of
discretionary spending is being spent
online while avoiding online shopping
altogether probably isn't realistic
there are things we can do to minimize
the creepy stocking from retailers so we
can shop more deliberately first set up
an email account for your online
shopping that way all the spam and
promotional offers won't be clogging
your primary Inbox
next you can delete cookies and
unremember your credit card numbers from
your browse
memory I know I know this will make
online shopping less convenient because
you'll have to keep re-entering your
info but remember we are trying to fight
brainless nests and make purchasing as
intentional as possible
eat a lers want shopping to be
effortless because they know that the
more steps involved the more chances
you'll have to realize that you don't
really need those fancy yoga socks if
you're not sure how to do this just
google how to erase cookies in the name
of your browser and lastly we strongly
recommend setting a hard cap for online
expenditures by opening a separate
checking account or online wallet that's
only for shopping online top it off with
how much you want to allow yourself to
spend per month when is empty well
you'll just have to wait till next month
to get that 4k blu-ray of The Matrix I
admit it I love seeing those packages
show up at my door as much as the next
person but for most people shopping
online is a luxury the vast majority of
necessities like groceries and household
supplies are still purchased at
brick-and-mortar stores Detailers want
us to treat online shopping like a
normal habitual part of our lives but
any discretionary spending should still
be a special deliberate decision you
probably can't ever get away from online
advertising but you can at least be
aware of how it's trying to influence
your behavior and that's our two cents
are there any other ways online
advertisers are driving you crazy I'd
love to hear about it in the comments
[Music]
you